回転するボールについて教えるが、ボールでも回転でもない。今日はQiskitの授業で
スピンと呼ばれるこの量子的性質について、最初にその証拠を見つけた実験を通して話す
Qiskitの授業へようこそ。このシリーズでは、Qiskitを使って量子コンピューティング関連の
授業でよく取り上げられる基本的な概念を探っていく。各動画にはインタラクティブなモジュールも
説明欄にリンクされているので、ぜひ確認してほしい。今日は1922年のシュテルン＝ゲルラッハ
実験について話す。量子論の歴史で最も有名な実験の一つで、量子
スピンの働きを非常に明確に示している。だがそれはシュテルンやゲルラッハが示そうとしたものではなかった。実験はボーアモデルと呼ばれる
原子の新しい量子モデルを検証するために設計された。1913年にそれを提唱したニールス・ボーアにちなんで名付けられたモデルで、電子は
離散的な軌道を核の周りを回り、光子を吸収または放出することでそれらの軌道間を遷移できる
というものだ。各軌道は量子化された角運動量を持ち、それはHと呼ばれる微小な基本定数の整数倍だった
1910年代から20年代初頭にかけて、量子力学はまったく新しいものだった。あまりに新しかったため
まだ量子力学とも呼ばれていなかった。そのため、誰もがボーアモデルに納得していたわけではなく、ある物理学者は
オットー・シュテルンといい、それを嫌っていた。彼はこのモデルをナンセンスと呼び、ボーアが
正しいと証明されたら物理学を辞めると脅すほどだった。シュテルンはモデルが間違っていると証明することに強くこだわり、それを検証する独創的な方法を考え出した
そしてワルター・ゲルラッハを引き込んで実験を設計・実施した。結果的に彼はボーアが間違っていると証明できず
自分自身が間違っていると証明することになった。実験はあまりにシンプルで、結果もあまりに鮮明だったため、
量子力学が原子スケールで支配しているという議論をほぼ決着させた。当時は気づいていなかったが
シュテルンとゲルラッハの実験は、電子の固有スピンの決定的な証拠も発見していた。それは
磁性、超伝導、そして多くの化学現象を説明するために不可欠な、自然の新しい基本的な性質だ
今日はシュテルン＝ゲルラッハ実験の仕組み、古典的に期待される結果、
そしてシュテルンとゲルラッハが実際に発見したことを説明する。それからQiskitとIBM量子コンピュータで
自分自身のシュテルン＝ゲルラッハ型実験を実行する方法を見せる。シュテルン＝ゲルラッハ実験の
基本的なアイデアは、原子中の電子の角運動量が量子化されているかどうかを判断する方法を見つけることだった
ボーアが予測したように、あるいはシュテルンが期待したようにそうでないかを。彼らは電子の角運動量が各原子の周りに
小さな磁場を生じさせるという事実を利用した。つまりそれらを小さな棒磁石と考えることができる
実験はこういったものだった。銀原子を満たした炉と、北極と南極を持つ磁場があった
ここに北極と南極がある
磁場は上部が強く下部が弱かったため、上向きの勾配が生じた
最後にスクリーンがあった。実験では炉が銀原子を加熱して蒸発させ
各原子の小さな棒磁石の向きが完全にランダムな状態で炉から飛び出した。そして原子は
磁場を通過した。原子は上下に押されたが、その力はこの磁場勾配に対する
各原子の北極の方向によって決まった。そして原子がスクリーンに当たった。シュテルンとゲルラッハはスクリーン上の
どこに原子が当たったかを見ることで電子の角運動量について学べた。シュテルンは実験の原子が
これまで説明してきたように振る舞うと予想していた。古典物理学の法則に従う小さな棒磁石のように。
古典的にはこれらの小さな原子磁石はあらゆるランダムな方向に向くことができる。だから
磁場を通過する際にそれらの向きに応じて様々な力を受けて上下に動く可能性がある。勾配と
同じ方向を向いている磁石は大きな上向きの力を受け、反対方向では
大きな下向きの力を受ける。その中間にある場合は弱い力になる。原子が
勾配に垂直を向いている場合は力を受けず直進し続ける。この様々な力の範囲があるため
原子はすべてスクリーン上の異なる垂直な点に当たるはずだ。彼らが作るパターンは
スクリーン上でこのようなものになるはずだった。しかしシュテルンと
ゲルラッハが見たのはそれではなく、代わりにスクリーン上に完全に別々な2つの原子の塊を見た。中間には
原子がなかった。当時はこれを説明する正しい理論がなかったが、今では彼らがこれを見たのは
すべての電子がスピンの形で固有角運動量を持っており、それが取れる値は常に2つのうちの1つだけだからだとわかっている
棒磁石の描像では、原子磁石に許された向きは2つだけということになる。この2つの向きを
スピンアップとスピンダウンと呼ぶ。量子コンピュータのqubitは
このタイプのスピン系に似ている。一部の量子コンピュータは実際に電子スピン状態から作られたqubitを使っている
だからQiskitとIBM量子コンピュータのqubitを使って独自のシュテルン＝ゲルラッハ実験を実行できる
電子のスピンアップ状態をqubitのゼロ状態にマッピングし、スピンダウン状態を1状態にマッピングする
qubitの1状態に。銀粒子が炉から出てきたとき、磁気モーメントがランダムに向いていた。
シュテルン＝ゲルラッハ実験は、ゼロ状態から始まる単一qubitを持つシンプルな量子circuitを作ることでモデル化できる
これをcircuit図と呼び、上のワイヤーがqubitで、qubitに適用される操作が
ワイヤー上のボックスとして表示される。RXとRZのボックスは量子gateで
原子の磁気的向きを効果的に回転させる。ランダムなThetaとF値を選んでqubitを
ランダムな量だけ回転させることができる。これはランダムなスピン向きで原子を放出する炉を模倣している。グレーのボックスは
測定で、qubitがゼロか1かを教えてくれ、その測定を古典的なbitに送る。
Cとラベルされた二重線がそれだ。この部分は、スクリーン上のどこに当たったかを見ることで原子がスピンアップかスピンダウンかを測定することに相当する
Qiskitのプリミティブであるsamplerを使って実験を何度も実行できる。それぞれThetaとfに異なるランダム値を用いる
100回サンプリングすると、このような測定ヒストグラムが得られる。約
50%の確率でqubitはゼロと測定され、50%の確率で状態1になる。これはシュテルン
とゲルラッハが見たのと同じ結果だ。常にスピンアップかスピンダウンで、その中間にはならない。この時点でこう思うかもしれない。まあ
もちろん、2つの離散的な結果が得られた。デジタル量子コンピューターで実験を行ったわけだが、それは常に
0か1しか返さない。これは事実だが、量子コンピューターがバイナリの結果を返す根本的な理由、そもそも
Quantum Computingが機能する理由そのものが、SternとGerlachが最初に発見したスピン量子化にある
IBM量子コンピューターのqubitはスピンに基づいていないが、他の多くの量子コンピューターはそうだ。つまり、
量子コンピューターでStern-Gerlach実験を行うことで、スピン量子化を実際に再発見できる
1922年以来、元のStern-Gerlach実験に対する無数の拡張実験が行われてきた。これらの拡張は
同じ原子ビームを複数のStern-Gerlach装置に通し、異なる状況でスピンがどう振る舞うかを調べるものだ
ここに一例がある。原子を1つの装置に通してビームを2つに分離し、スピンアップのビームと
スピンダウンのビームに対応させ、それぞれのビームをそれぞれの独立した
装置に通す。Qiskitでこの実験に対応するcircuitは前回と似ているが、
measurementが1つではなく2つになっている。ここでは、オーブンの効果を模倣したランダムな回転を
Hadamard gateに置き換えた。Hadamardを適用するとオーブンと同じ測定確率が得られるが、
使い方がずっとシンプルだ。なので1回目を測定し、次に2回目を測定する。
この実験の測定ヒストグラムはこのようになっており、X軸上のビット文字列は
2回の測定結果に対応している。qubitが両方とも0と測定された場合は0 0のビット文字列に対応し、
最初に0、次に1と測定された場合は1 0などに対応する。最初の実験でスピンアップと測定されると、
2回目もスピンアップになるようだ。スピンダウンの原子も同様だ。つまり最初の実験では
アップとダウンを測定する確率が等しかったが、2回目の実験では結果がすでに決まっていた。なので
2つ目のStern-Gerlach装置それぞれの端にあるスクリーンには、それぞれ1つのスポットしか映らない。1つのスクリーンには
スピンアップの原子がすべて、もう1つのスクリーンにはスピンダウンの原子がすべて映る。次の実験では、
純粋にスピンアップの原子のビームから始めよう。実際の物理的なStern-Gerlach実験では、これを行うには
Stern-Gerlach装置に通し、下に偏向されたビームをブロックすればいい。そうすれば上に偏向された原子はすべて
スピンアップだ。このビームを別のStern-Gerlach装置に通してみよう。ただし今度は磁石を90°回転させて、
磁場勾配がこの方向に進んでいる原子を上下ではなく左右に偏向させる。スポットは1つ見えるだろうか、それとも2つ、
あるいはまったく違うものが見えるだろうか？この実験では、
Qiskitで次のcircuitを実行する。この実験の原子ビームがすべてスピンアップなので、zero状態から始める。
次にこのHadamard gateがXとZの座標を入れ替え、
Stern-Gerlach装置を回転させた効果をもたらす。これで上下ではなく左右のスピン射影を測定している。ここで得られる
測定ヒストグラムはこのようになっている。X方向のスピンも2つの値しか取れないことがわかる。
これをスピンレフトとスピンライトと呼ぶことができる。つまりこの実験は、Z方向でスピンアップと測定された
スピンのX射影を測定すると、等しい確率でスピンレフトまたはスピンライトになることを示している。最後に
この違いを本当に際立たせるために、古典的な予測ともう一度比較してみよう。古典的には、
小さな原子の棒磁石が装置の磁場勾配に対して垂直を向いていた場合、
その原子に作用する力はゼロのはずだと言った。上にも下にも偏向されないはずで、その場合スクリーンの中央に
単一のスポットが見えるだけだ。ところが実際には2つのスポットが見える。半分の原子はスピンレフトで、半分はスピンライトだ。
以前にアップと測定されていたにもかかわらず。量子力学的な観点からすると、スピンアップを
上を向くベクトルと、スピンダウンを下を向くベクトルと同一視したくなるかもしれないが、前回の実験からわかるように
それほど単純ではない。ここで何が起きているかを本当に理解するには、
量子重ね合わせと測定というトピックをさらに深く掘り下げる必要がある。それはまた別の日の動画だ。量子力学が
どのように機能するかについて多くの疑問が残るように、SternとGerlachもそうだった。彼らの実験はすべてを
説明するわけではなかったが、自然界を理解するうえで量子力学が不可欠であることを確立するのに大いに貢献した。
これは量子力学において最も重要な基礎実験の一つで、運動量の量子化を証明し、
スピンと呼ばれる自然界の新たな基本的性質の証拠をもたらした。量子世界のルールを本当に把握し
理解するために、SternやGerlachのような物理学者たちは実験を設計し、予測を立て、
時には間違えながら、泥臭く取り組んだ。自分でやってみることに勝るものはない。
だから、実際の量子実験を自分で試したいなら、説明欄にリンクされているStern-Gerlachモジュールに
アクセスしてみてくれ。見てくれてありがとう、また次回。